I'll just tell you we've been to the
bottom the oceans we've been to ancient
Greek mythology we've been to the past
and the future flash into the digital
world with cyborg. We still got to go to
space, so the Green Lantern's and the
Green Lantern Corps will be coming to
join the Justice League universe.
Except to say expect the unexpected
Because if the past 8 years has
shown us anything
It's that this universe is far bigger than
any of us could have dared imagine.
Every existence multiplied by
possibility
Life, a precious gift persevering in the
face of every obstacle
until finally
the Age of Heroes was born.
And please don't make
the supersuit green or animated
Just cleaning up the timelines!
You're welcome Canada!
Welcome back everyone,
it's Charlie this is going to be
my new video for the Green Lantern HBO
series that's happening in 2021 and all
the Green Lantern scenes and Easter eggs
that have been happening recently on the
DC TV shows the producers came out and
explained a whole bunch of details and
part of their special deal that they
made with Warner Brothers in DC to let
them do Green Lantern stuff and how it's
all connected so if you're brand new to
my channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos will do a Green Lantern
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be subscriber and let me know
what you want them to do on that Green
Lantern HBO show so we'll just break
this down top five style starting with
number five the Green Lantern HBO show
like I said won't premiere till at least
next year in 2021
but they aren't in the middle of
developing it like I said the arrow
verse producers Greg Berlanti mostly is
the person that's also behind the HBO
Green Lantern show fun Easter egg they
were also pushed off of the Green
Lantern movie back in 2011 the Ryan
Reynolds Green Lantern movie they were
working on it for a little while but
then they got kicked off the movie the
good news and all that is that if you're
disappointed in what happened with the
Green Lantern movie they aren't
responsible for what that turned into
but just because it's the same producers
that are making all the air / shows in
the Green Lantern HBO show doesn't mean
the grant gustin's flash for instance is
going to show up every single week crossing
over with Green Lantern on HBO we're
supposed to treat it like an alternate
universe for now that's why the crisis
on Infinite Earths
ending scene was so important letting
you know that that Green Lantern stuff
is taking place on earth 12 in an
alternate universe they did reuse
footage from Ryan Reynolds Green Lantern
movie to do that but as you would expect
Ryan Reynolds himself is not attached to
the new project and they'll be doing a
new version of Hal Jordan amongst the
other most famous Green Lantern Comics
characters Warner Brothers is calling it
a big-budget event series and because
it's only going to be available on the
new HBO streaming service HBO max that
implies it's only going to be 8 to 10
episode
tops per season but it will run multiple
seasons really easy comparison to make
would be the mandalorian on Disney Plus
they spend around 12 million dollars per
episode of the mandalorian and that's
because it's so expensive but it looks
amazing so if you ever wondered why the
episode count was so low for the
Mandalorian that's why but number 4
the Diggle Green Lantern arrows seen
from the arrow series finale means what
you think it means but the producers did
explain why they only showed him opening
the green glowing ring box and you
didn't see him in an actual costume
they said the Warner Brothers and DC
were planning something really special
with the new Green Lantern HBO series
that wouldn't premiere for a couple
years
so during arrow season 7 about a year
ago they did the deal with greg berlanti
to develop that Green Lantern HBO show
around that time they also told them
that they could give Diggle a Green
Lantern ring during arrow season aid so
they knew a year in advance that this
scene was going to happen on arrow the
arrow people said that they just decided
to save that moment for the arrow finale
because it was a great way to send the
character out letting you know that
there were big things coming in his
future but the funny thing is is they
said that part of the terms of their
agreement although legal red tape with
Warner Brothers in DC allowing them to
use Green Lantern characters in the
arrow verse or that they couldn't talk
about the future of Green Lantern in the
arrow verse with the press
basically Fight Club rules you can do
Green Lantern stuff this year as long as
you don't tell everyone are big plans
for Green Lantern's stuff happening next
year so that's why you've probably seen
the producers talking about the arrow
finale saying anything could happen we
don't know what's going to happen with
Diggle he opened that box it sure seems
like he has a Green Lantern ring so if
you thought that Diggle Green Lantern
scene was kind of weird in its execution
it's just because of the rules they were
given and that's also why they didn't
give Diggle the Green Lantern ring
during the actual crisis on Infinite
Earths crossover episodes because I
think a lot of us were expecting them to
do some kind of Green Lantern stuff
during the crossover which they did but
just not what we expected so number
three there is a difference between
the Green Lantern HBO characters in the
arrowverse Green Lantern characters
everyone was asking me after the arrow
finale and the Diggle Green Lantern seen
if Diggle was going to cross over with
the Green Lantern HBO show now they have
to give him a costume at some point they
have to explain how he trains with the
new
in the diggle character was never a
comic-book character to begin with never
a green lantern Diggle was created
during the first season of arrow for the
TV show then later DC Comics added him
to the green arrow comics in that way
he's kind of like the Harley Quinn
character that she didn't debut in the
comics before showing up on a TV series
she debuted on Batman the Animated
Series first then they put her in the
comics the Green Lantern HBO show is
going to be its own thing with the Corps
Green Lantern comic book characters I
mean never say never but Diggle for the
most part is going to stay inside the earth
prime universe like they said on the
arrow finale he's moving to Metropolis
there will be a DC TV Superman TV show
later this year with Tyler hoechlin
earth prime Superman and his twin sons
so Diggle is probably just going to be the
Green Lantern of the arrowverse proper
and just crossover with Superman on his
TV show pretty easy to understand and
then they'll let the Green Lantern HBO
show just be its own thing like Titans
is off in its own universe doing its own
thing before crisis on Infinite Earths
happened and all those multiverse scenes
in the crossovers I wouldn't have
expected any of the arrowverse
characters to show up in the really big
movie stuff that's happening but if they
went as far to crossover Ezra Miller's
flash with the Grant Gustin flash
something I never expected that they
would do that I suppose anything is
possible that was seriously probably the
best seen from the crossover no also the
flash number two the newer press release
on the Green Lantern HBO show is that it
will cover a couple different decades of
history in a couple different Green
Lantern's including Sinestro and
eventually the Sinestro Corps there are
a billion different Green Lantern's but
they said there be two main ones in
addition to Sinestro and I think you can
all guess which ones they didn't say
anything about how they tell the story
if there'd be flashbacks or if they tell
it in a linear way but they'll probably
start with an origin story for its
Edisto in the past then a little while
later they'll do the origin story for
Hal Jordan when he gets his ring
Sinestro will be one of his mentor's
then later in the timeline as you would
probably expect they'll do the Jon
Stewart origin story in a slightly older
Hal Jordan will become his mentor in its
some point in the future Sinestro will
turn to the dark side take the yellow
ring of fear and eventually create the
Sinestro Corps to rival the Green
Lantern Corps they didn't say how many
seasons but I'd assume at least four to
five seasons remember only eight to ten
episodes per season probably so don't
expect all of that stuff to happen in
the first season but yes number one
this is the path to a blackest night big
event series like everyone had hoped for
they'd eventually get to that's huge so
they could always decide to do blackest
night is a big movie Justice League
crossover event because of the
big-budget HBO Green Lantern show though
I think that they've temporarily
canceled the Green Lantern Corps movie
that they had talked about a couple of
years ago same thing happened with the
Boba Fett movie in the Obi one movie in
the Star Wars universe those became
Disney Plus big-budget series so no
surprise that DC and Warner Brothers
would do the same thing there's even
talk of them doing a new Blue Beetle HBO
max series so don't be surprised if you
hear about more big-budget series like
the mandalorian happening inside the DC
Universe on the HBO Mac service but if
the Green Lantern HBO show goes well and
it seems like it will based on
everything that's going into it and all
the money they're spending on it
those Green Lantern's would be the ones
that show up in the next Justice League
movie I'll do more videos for the Green
Lantern HBO show and Green Lantern air
overstuff as they release more details
they'll probably some more Easter eggs
going on in the back half of the season
and obviously when all the shows start
next year to the Superbowl is this
weekend I will be doing Super Bowl
trailer videos for the bigger stuff but
leave all your requests in the comments
below I know there's going to be a Black
Widow trailer I'm not expecting a new
Wonder Woman 1984 trailer for a little
while longer but if anything posts I'll
be sure to do a video about it
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big video faithful Steve
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details
everyone click here for my new Marvel
Eternals teaser breakdown and click here
to watch that crisis on Infinite Earths
scene of flash meeting the Ezra Miller
flash again thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!